[Musique]
bonjour charbel nahas merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin dans la
matinale d'ayrté france alors on imagine
11 jours difficiles en vue pour les
libanais comment est ce que la
population s'est préparée à ce
confinement total puis comme vous l'avez
très bien monté dans le reportage
les gens se sont précipités pour faire
les provisions
cette situation au liban il faut pas
l'oublier
l'explosion de la coved se conjugue avec
les effets de données fondremand
économique totale et d'un effondrement
politique alors même que la pandémie
explose
on vous l'avait dit les hôpitaux le
shinya à accepter les malades parce
qu'ils ne sont pas payés depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années et que les les
qualifications continuent d'être
bloquées alors que la monnaie a perdu
80% de sa valeur
nous assistons à une hémorragie flux
d'émigration massif des médecins des
infirmiers des un film neige toujours
pour les raisons économiques évidentes
et nous n'avons pas de gouvernement
depuis depuis maintenant 5 mois et cela
évidemment ce sont les deux effets se
mélangent
ils produisent d'une part une
aggravation des conditions sanitaires
mais en retour cette cette panique
accentue le désespoir de la population
et par conséquent prolonge la durée 10 2
de régime politique absolument
catastrophique
alors pour revenir à la situation
sanitaire admire confinement avait été
imposé à l'issue des fêtes de fin
d'année avec un couvre feu nocturne qui
débutait à 18 heures
les contaminations lisez ont explosé
selon vous les mesures elles n'ont pas
été elles n'ont pas été assez respecté
par les libanais n'ont ils n'ont pas été
vraiment respecté il ya cela différentes
raisons d'une part que le fait qu'une
grande partie de la population libanaise
a perdu ces emplois sont épargnés par
conséquent pour maintenir un niveau
minimum de revenus bon les gens
continuent autant qu'ils peuvent
d'exercer les activités informelles pas
si par là et par conséquent cela
enfreint les dispositions thé hollies
coeur du confinement et il yad'autres le
parce que je mentionnais tout à l'heure
le sentiment de désespoir qui pousse à
une attitude fataliste qui est
excessivement nocives
parce que bon l aile configure
différemment si vous voulez les
comportements de ce à quoi on pouvait
s'attendre il n'y a aucune compensation
il n'y a pas deux prisons et la jeunesse
est compétent désemparé pratiquement
c'est une population qui est en instance
en instance de départ ou de fuite que ce
soit vers l'étranger ou pour ceux se
rabattent si vous voulez chacun dans son
coin et essayer de tirer sur l'époque du
jeu à son niveau individuel un mécanisme
des daims devait être enclenchée il
avait été promis d'être bien surveillé
par emmanuel macron qui n'a pas pu se
déplacer au liban comment est ce que
vous voyez l'issue justement de cette
crise politique et économique grave
est ce que la population quand même on
reçoit de l'aide il ya évidemment
quelques circuits dette notamment qui
concerne les réfugiés si les liens mais
la tentative que le président français a
enclenché déjà en août a visiblement
échoué
elle a échoué pour plusieurs raisons les
américains évidemment n'ont pas facilité
le jeu parce qu'ils ont
lancer des campagnes de 2,2 de
désignation si vous voulez en fonction
des lois qui les autorise à imposer des
sanctions en dehors de leur territoire
donc ça a bloqué le jeu politique il va
d'ailleurs
oui des sanctions donc jules différents
acteurs politiques ce qui à l'en faut
c'est donc les augmenter les complexités
et il ya aussi le fait que les acteurs
politiques libanais se complaisent dans
cette situation que je mentionnais de de
fatalisme et ils n'ont aucun intérêt à
se proposer en façade dans un
gouvernement pour faire face aux choix
difficiles qui se restreignent pas
évidemment à la question de la copie
mais qui touchent évidemment
l'effondrement politique économique et
la situation régionale
donc il ya un jeu très pervers qui se
développe qui nous lie le fatalisme le
de la désespérance et qui c'est
désespérant se substitue à la colère qui
normalement aurait dû prévaloir face à
ce désastre total
cette manipulation est excessivement
perverse et je pense que d'initiative
française n'a pas réussi à t-elle c est
le fait qu elle se rabat
bien que ce soit tout à fait
compréhensible sur l'assistance
humanitaire et quelque chose qui lui
aussi est ambigu parce que healy
l'autolyse si vous voulez le seul régime
complètement poulies si vous voulez à se
maintenir ou l'otan que la population
est aidée à sarah que maud et si vous
voulez c'est un nous sommes monsieur sur
le sud le fil du rasoir à ce niveau là
et je pense que il faut prendre acte de
la désespérance comme étant un facteur
politique que vous savez quand vous êtes
désespérée que le pied sur vous même
vous accepter n'importe quoi merci à
vous charbel nahas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans la matinale de rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes secrétaire
général du mouvement citoyen et
citoyenne